let's have a look at how petrol prices
are doing well latest figures show the
average
price of petrol has risen once again
hitting another new record of
188.74 pence per litre that is up 0.04
pence in 24 hours up 3.34 pence in the
last seven days a similar story for
diesel with the average price hitting
196.36 pence that is up
0.26 pens from sunday
and an astonishing 5.16
pence from this time last week
well let's go live disguise aisha zaheed
who's in west london for us and i sure
prices are still going up despite the
fall in wholesale prices
yeah that's right we're still seeing
these absolutely eye-watering prices for
fuel that we have been seeing month on
month now now it's a bit of a split
picture the rac say that it's the
wholesale cost of petrol that's fallen
and it's fallen for the first time since
the jubilee weekend but they say even
when this is reflected into prices for
consumers that's only going to mean a
difference of one or two pence to prices
and then on the flip side the rac say
they expect the price of diesel to
increase to at least two pounds over the
next coming weeks or so potentially so
uh still significantly high prices and
like you said those average prices have
reached a record high again today petrol
is averaging uh
188.74 pence per litre whilst diesel is
averaging
196.36 pence per litre but those are
just averages depending on where you go
prices will be different here in this
four court they are significantly higher
than that both petrol and diesel are
more than 190 pence per liter and in
fact here diesel is
198.6 pence per litre really teetering
close to that two pound mark we've
spoken to people filling up their tanks
here today
and their shared concern their shared
worry and also shared frustration take a
listen to what some of them said
[Music]
it's not just fuel it's it's all pointed
at working class people
you know
it's working-class people that haven't
got enough anyway now you get all the
electric bills the gas bills the fuel
bills
it's hitting working-class people no one
else
um i think it's a joke to be honest
because you know you used to be able to
fill your car up for like 40 pounds and
now it's like doubled and i don't see
why it's gone up so much when obviously
everything else is going up but your
wages don't go up
well it'd be nice if some of the petrol
companies didn't keep all the billions
of pounds that they earn and actually
pass some of it onto the customers or
you know they don't have to keep
increasing the prices because they're
making huge profits already and
obviously the government taxes the
petrol so
i'm not sure who's the worst out of
those two
so there's frustration there and also
lots of people have spoken to us about
the cost of living and just how
difficult fuel prices being
significantly higher throw into the mix
as well and some of the people we've
spoken to have had to reconsider the
ways they're getting to work the way in
which they are working so the rac say
with these wholesaler prices being cut
down it really is going to be a big test
for retailers
and they're going to face scrutiny to
the whether or not they reflect these
that cuts in their prices to consumers